le public Sénat un mot sur ce qui va se
jouer dans quelques minutes il va y
avoir la composition d'une commission
d'enquête parlementaire que vous avez
souhaité elle vise et bien à soulever
les questions que pose le réseau social
Tik Tok quel est l'ambition de votre
commission d'enquête l'ambition c'est de
lever les très nombreuses zones d'ombre
qu'il y a sur ce réseau des zones
d'ombres il y en a sur toutes les
plateformes américaines chinoises etc
mais je dirais que c'est encore un
peut-être un peu plus opaque chez Tik
Tok mais les problèmes de transfert de
données dans d'autres pays à partir de
des pays européens les problèmes de
de modération concernant les plus jeunes
et le problème qui se pose
particulièrement à Tik Tok c'est que
c'est les réseaux qui dont les abonnés
sont les plus jeunes la plupart sont des
adolescents et il faut bien le dire une
bonne partie sont des enfants donc un
public particulièrement fragile et puis
d'autres il y a des questions notamment
sur les accusations d'espionnage et de
propagande qui sont régulièrement
portées contre cette plateforme vous
avez dit Tik Tok soulève ça donne en
location quant à la gestion des données
de ses utilisateurs à la transparence de
son fonctionnement c'est ça qui vous
aussi rend curieux sur cette application
c'est notamment ça je pense qu'on aurait
pas pu rêver d'une meilleure coïncidence
puisque au moment où on a annoncé la
création de cette commission d'enquête
la Commission européenne a décidé
d'interdire à tous ces fonctionnaires
et le Parlement aujourd'hui mais avant
la Commission à tous il faut
fonctionnaires de télécharger
l'application ce qui avait déjà été
décidé aux États-Unis et au Canada et en
fait dans d'autres pays par conséquent
et en disant très clairement que c'était
à cause du transfert de données alors
est-ce qu'il faut parler d'espionnage ou
pas moi je suis pas qualifié pour le
faire mais ce problème de rangement des
données depuis l'Europe jusqu'à la Chine
c'est évidemment un sujet il nous reste
quelques secondes que de madurée il y a
peut-être des millions d'utilisateurs de
l'application en France peut-être
certains qui nous regardent est-ce que
vous leur dites méfiez-vous de cette
application même pour le grand public
alors certes vous allez travailler
dessus pendant six mois donc vous
peut-être un avis plus définitif
cette appli je pense en tout cas qu'il
faut être vigilant c'est la raison de
cette commission d'enquête comme vous le
dites dans six mois on dira ce qu'on en
pense mais pour le moment la Commission
européenne a déjà expliqué que elle se
méfiait elle donc de notre côté on va
essayer d'être le plus vigilant possible
et en quelque secondes vous allez
auditionner des dirigeants français de
Tik Tok c'est cela on va auditionner
beaucoup de monde notamment des
dirigeants fantastiques mais aussi des
chercheurs mais aussi des revendent de
la Commission Informatique et Liberté de
de l'annecy de d'autres institutions qui
travaillent sur ces sujets pour voir
essayer de lever une après l'autre
toutes les zones d'ombre dont je parlais
tout à l'heure